the shaky science show clips
so speaking of interventions is there
any advice that you'd give to people now
if they wanted to help improve like
their health plan or their health in
general what would you advise
yeah i always sound like your mother
when i answer this
yeah they're really four things that you
can do right now i mean if you want to
try supplements great try them i mean
we're still finalizing some validation
on a lot of things but there's a lot of
potential candidates but outside of that
it's about lifestyle and there's really
four factors
there's exercise
some combination of cardiovascular
resistance exercise with resistance
training
healthy diet which we could talk all day
about but you know don't eat too many
calories that's a good start
maybe consider some of these
intermittent fasting strategies
and then i would argue to have a
balanced uh portions of macronutrients
in your diet
stress
it's kind of hard to study this in
animals but i think the amount of stress
you feel is a big driver of aging
and then sleep which is not that easy to
modify sometimes but sleep quality
declines with age and i think it's
important to
try to mitigate that
but you know the question is how do you
do that and ultimately it has to be
changes you could make that are
sustainable which means that you enjoy
them
you know if i tell you to be a vegan
marathon runner you're probably not
going to do it so
i think it really takes people to think
about their it's personalized people
should think about their lives look at
where they can start to make slow
changes
uh that are toward health and i think if
they do that you know it's kind of it'll
keep growing because
what you'll realize is you feel better
now not just 20 years from now and
that's especially true of exercise
there's a
there's a there's a threshold you have
to get over before you really feel the
benefits of it if you don't exercise and
you start running or doing something the
first two months
is mostly misery
uh you know but once you get over a
certain threshold
then you find that it feels good to run
you know and it actually is
takes away stress to run and
it gives you more energy and so but you
have to get over those barriers the same
thing is true of like taking sugar out
of your diet if you talk to people that
switch from coke to diet coke
they hate the diet coke at the beginning
and eight weeks later they hate the coke
because it's way too sweet you know but
it takes time your body doesn't
transition quickly so
it's about sustainability and that's
that's the key for lifestyle
you